I am a capitalist and after a 30-year
career in capitalism spanning three
dozen companies generating tens of
billions of dollars in market value I'm
not just in the top 1% I'm in the top
point zero one percent of all earners
today I have come to share the secrets
of our success because rich capitalists
like me have never been richer so the
question is how do we do it
how do we manage to grab an
ever-increasing share of the economic
pie every year is it the rich people are
smarter than we were 30 years ago is it
that we're working harder than we once
did
are we taller better-looking sadly now
it all comes down to just one thing
economics because here's the dirty
secret there was a time in which the
economics profession worked in the
public interest for everyone but in the
neoliberal era today they work only for
big corporations and billionaires and
that is creating a little bit of a
problem we could choose to enact
economic policies that raise taxes on
the rich regulate powerful corporations
or raise wages for workers we have done
it before but neoliberal economists
would warn that all of these policies
would be a terrible mistake because
raising taxes always kills economic
growth in any form of government
regulation is inefficient and raising
wages always kills jobs well as a
consequence of that thinking over the
last thirty years in the USA alone the
top one percent has grown twenty one
trillion dollars richer while the bottom
50% have grown nine hundred billion
dollars poor a pattern of widening
inequality that is largely repeated
itself across the world
and yet as middle-class families
struggle to get by on wages that have
not budged in about 40 years neoliberal
economists continue to warn that the
only reasonable response to the painful
dislocations of austerity and
globalization is even more austerity and
globalization so what is a society to do
well it's super clear to me what we need
to do we need a new economics so
economics has been described as the
dismal science and for good reason
because as much of as it is taught today
it isn't a science at all in spite of
all of the dazzling mathematics in fact
a growing number of academics and
practitioners have concluded that
neoliberal economic theory is
dangerously wrong and that today's
growing crises of rising inequality and
growing political instability are the
direct result of decades of bad economic
theory what we now know is that the
economics that made me so rich isn't
just wrong it's backwards because it
turns out it isn't capital that creates
economic growth its people and it isn't
self-interest that promotes the public
good
it's reciprocity and it isn't
competition that produces our prosperity
its cooperation but we can now see is
that an economics that is neither just
nor inclusive can never sustain the high
levels of so social cooperation
necessary to enable a modern society to
thrive so where did we go wrong well it
turns out that it's become painfully
obvious that the fundamental assumptions
that undergird neoliberal economic
theory are just objectively false and so
today first I want to take you through
some of those mistaken assumptions and
then after describe where the science
suggests prosperity actually comes from
so
neoliberal economic assumption number
one is that the market is an efficient
equilibrium system which basically means
that if one thing in the economy like
wages goes up another thing in the
economy like jobs must go down so for
example in Seattle where I live when in
2014 we passed our nation's first $15
minimum wage the neoliberals
freaked out over their precious
equilibrium if you raise the price of
labor they warned businesses will
purchase less of it
thousands of low-wage workers will lose
their jobs the restaurants will closed
except they didn't the unemployment rate
fell dramatically the restaurant
business in Seattle boomed why because
there is no equilibrium because raising
wages doesn't kill jobs it creates them
because for instance when restaurant
owners are suddenly required to pay
restaurant workers enough so that now
even they can afford to eat in
restaurants doesn't shrink the
restaurant business it grows it
obviously the second assumption is that
the price of something is always equal
to its value which basically means that
if you earn $50,000 a year and I earn 50
million dollars a year that's because I
produce a thousand times as much value
as you now it mean it will not surprise
you to learn that this is a very
comforting assumption if you're a CEO
paying yourself fifty million dollars a
year but playing your workers poverty
wages but please take it from somebody
who's run dozens of businesses this is
nonsense
people are not paid what they are worth
they are paid what they have the power
to negotiate and wages falling share of
GDP is not
workers have become less productive but
because employers have become more
powerful and and by pretending that the
giant imbalance in power between capital
and labor doesn't exist neoliberal
economic theory became essentially a
protection racket for the rich the third
assumption and by far the most
pernicious is a behavioral model that
describes human beings is something
called Homo economicus which basically
means that we are all perfectly selfish
perfectly rational and relentlessly
self-maximizing but just ask yourselves
is it plausible that every single time
for your entire life when you did
something nice for somebody else all you
were doing was maximizing your own
utility is it plausible that when a
soldier jumps on a grenade to defend
fellow soldiers they're just promoting
their narrow self-interest if you think
that's nuts cron turi to any reasonable
moral intuition that's because it is and
according to the latest science not true
but it is this behavioral model which is
at the cold cruel heart of neoliberal
economics and it is as it is as morally
corrosive as it is scientifically wrong
because if we accept at face value that
humans are fundamentally selfish and
then we look around the world at all of
the unambiguous prosperity in it then it
follows logically then it must be true
by definition that billions of
individual acts of selfishness magically
transubstantiated to prosperity and the
common good if we humans are merely
selfish maximizers then selfishness is
the cause of our prosperity under this
economic logic greed is good
widening inequality is efficient and the
only purpose of the corporation can be
to enrich shareholders because to do
otherwise would be too slow
economic growth and harm the economy
overall and it is this gospel of
selfishness which forms the ideological
cornerstone of neoliberal economics a
way of thinking which has produced
economic policies which have enabled me
and my rich buddies in the top 1% to
grab virtually all of the met offensive
growth over the last 40 years but if
instead we accept the latest empirical
research real science which correctly
describes human beings as highly
cooperative reciprocal and intuitively
moral creatures then it follows
logically that it must be cooperation
and not selfishness that is the cause of
our prosperity and it isn't our
self-interest but rather our inherent
reciprocity that is humanity's economic
superpower so you know at the heart of
this new economics is a story about
ourselves that grants us permission to
be our best selves and unlike the old
economics this is a story that is
virtuous and also has the virtue of
being true now I want to emphasize that
this new economics is not something I
have personally imagined or invented its
theories and models are being developed
and refined in universities around the
world building on some of the best new
research in economics complexity theory
evolutionary theory psychology
anthropology and other disciplines and
although this new economics does not yet
have its own textbook or even a commonly
agreed-upon name in broad strokes its
explanation of where prosperity comes
from goes something like this so market
capitalism is an evolutionary system in
which prosperity emerges through a
positive feedback loop between
increasing amounts of innovation and
creasing amounts of consumer demand
innovation is the process by which we
solve human problems
consumer demand is the mechanism through
which the market selects for useful
innovations and as we solve more
problems we become more prosperous but
as we become more prosperous our
problems and solutions become more
complex and this increasing technical
complexity requires ever higher levels
of social and economic cooperation in
order to produce the more highly
specialized products that define a
modern economy now the old economics is
correct of course the competition plays
a crucial role in how markets work but
what it fails to see is it is largely a
competition between highly cooperative
groups competition between firms
competitions between networks of firms
competition between nations and anyone
who knows who's ever run a successful
business now is that building a
cooperative team by including the
talents of everyone is almost always a
better strategy than just a bunch of
selfish jerks so how do we meet how do
we leave neoliberalism behind and build
a more sustainable more prosperous and
more equitable society the New Economics
suggests just five rules of thumb first
is that successful economies are not
jungles they're Gardens which is to say
that markets like Gardens must be tended
that the market is the greatest social
technology ever invented for solving
human problems but unconstrained by
social norms or democratic regulation
markets inevitably create more problems
than they solve climate change the great
financial crisis of 2008 or two easy
examples the second the second rule is
that inclusion creates economic growth
so the neoliberal idea that inclusion is
this fancy luxury to be afforded if and
when we have growth is both wrong and
backwards the economy is people
including more people in more ways is
what causes economic growth in market
economies the third principle is the
purpose of the corporation is not merely
to enrich shareholders the greatest
grift in contemporary economic life is
the neoliberal idea that the only
purpose of the corporation and the only
responsibility of executives is to
enrich themselves and shareholders the
new economics must and can insist that
the purpose of the corporation is to
improve the welfare of all stakeholders
customers workers community and
shareholders alike rule for greed is not
good being rapacious doesn't make you a
capitalist it makes you a sociopath
[Applause]
[Music]
and in an economy as dependent upon
cooperation at scale as ours sociopathy
is as bad for business as it is for
society and fifth and finally unlike the
laws of physics the laws of economics
are a choice now neoliberal economic
theory has sold itself to you as
unchangeable natural law when in fact
its social norms and constructed
narratives based on pseudoscience if we
truly want a more equitable more
prosperous and more sustainable economy
if we want high functioning democracies
and civil society we must have a new
economics and here's the good news
if we want a new economics all we have
to do is choose to have it thank you
[Music]
so Nick I'm sure you get this question a
lot if you're so unhappy with the
economic system why not just give all
your money away and join the 99% yeah no
yes
right you get that laughing so much
about taxes why don't you pay more and
you care so much about wages want to
promote a more and I could do that the
problem is it doesn't make that much
difference and I have discovered a
strategy that works literally a hundred
thousand times better okay which is to
use my money to build narratives and to
pass laws that require all the other
rich people to pay taxes and pay their
workers better and that so you know for
example the $15 minimum wage that we
cooked up is now affected thirty million
workers so that works better that's if
you change your mind we'll find some
takers for you thank you thank you very
much
[Music]